i got to say it was awesome to hear that
you guys are going to be on screen
together again after uh hell or high
water so cool to see you both ben
i got to ask how exciting is it for you
when you found out that you're going to
be doing this work with chris
well yeah i mean that that's that's
that's the joy of uh our version of
being a contractor
and that's what we do is as a
trade being our our our work when you
get uh someone you love and respect uh
it's like come hang out and make a
picture it's it's a great way to spend
time
yeah and i loved chris the scenes
between you also and kiefer sutherland
can you talk to me about the intensity
of that what that's like working with
him
it's great fun working with any of uh we
had an incredible supporting uh cast
behind us uh ferris ferris nina haas
keeper sutherland
julian jacobs uh just a whole crew of
incredible people
um and kiefer's a legend keeper's been
around for a long time and as part of an
acting dynasty he's a hell of a great
actor good guy great sport super
professional and
we were happy to have him
and i got to ask a question you guys
look like you're pros in this film you
look exactly like you know what you're
doing in these roles if we're out in the
field together the three of us
and i get hurt between the two you guys
who am i counting on
to save my life here
i'd say probably neither of us because
we're actors so we can really probably
make it look uh great but you'd probably
die i probably wouldn't make it right
but most likely
but we have a camera crew and you know
it looked cool
would you at least say a couple nice
things about me
like after i'm gone
up until then
yeah we can improv something yeah
we we have writers for that though so
i'm just an animatronic animal you know
i'm not even here right now i'm actually
a meta creation
oh wow right nice yeah hence the no legs
part that makes that makes a lot of
sense yeah just just this this is all i
made
yep nips up that's it
you guys spend a lot of time uh fighting
but not just fighting like fighting in
water there's a lot of like being wet
being underwater in this are you
actually spending a lot of time doing
this is it like take after take of being
under there or like how comfortable is
it water is the enemy in this movie
water in general or just fighting water
yeah it was uh we were in romanian
bucharest in the in the winter and there
was a fair amount of
being in a muddy pond
and tunnel
in the middle of the night that wasn't
necessarily the most fun but we made the
best of it uh
and then over some tank work and we had
to swim through uh
a tunnel and uh
yeah fair amount of fair amount of water
stuff that was warmer thank god that uh
i don't i don't think they were even
filming most of it i think the director
just liked to watch us struggle through
the tunnel he thought it was funny yeah
do it again
main street
uh finally before we go chris do you
have any words of wisdom for paul wesley
as he takes on the role of james kirk
i'm thrilled for him man it's uh
yeah so cool he'll do his thing and make
it his own and uh welcome to the club
right on guys tremendous work in this uh
absolutely thrilling picture thank you
so much for the time all the best thank
you be safe be safe up there
you